GREG GOT FELT IS NEXT.
♪
GREG: DID YOU HEAR?
SPREAD CORONAVIRUS.
THAT STINKS.
FLATULENCE IS AN AEROSOL
GENERATE THAT SPREADS THE VIRUS
THROUGH THE AIR.
THE DISCOVERY EMERGES FROM
AUSTRALIA BUT I’LL RESIST THE
URGE TO SAY CAME FROM DOWN
UNDER.
WE WENT TO AN EXPERT FOR
COMMENT.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS
UNCONTRADICTED, THE PRESIDENT
USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO ASK THEM
TO CHEAT AN ELECTION.
GREG: I GUESS THAT MAKES
IMPATIENT ZERO.
IT MAKES SENSE IF I SNEEZE OR
COUGH COULD PROPEL VIRUSES, WHY
CAN’T AIR BISCUITS?
IF IT’S TRUE, WE FINALLY HAVE AN
ILLNESS WE CAN BLAME ON THE
DOCK.
THIS IS WHY WE WEAR PANTS AND
MASKS, WHICH ARE JUST TIDY
FLIGHT HE’S FOR THE PROPERTY
LAST ARE NOW BECOMING ACCEPTABLE
ACCESSORIES.
ALONG WITH SOCIAL HYGIENE
PRACTICES, BEHAVIORS WE ARE
ENCOURAGING BUT NOT LITTERING
SHOPLIFTING AND NOT TAKING DON’T
MOMENT SERIOUSLY.
NO LONGER WEIRD TO WEAR A MASK,
IT WEIRD IF YOU DON’T.
CONGRESSMAN, IF YOU’RE GOING TO
CREATE A MASK ON THE FLY, MAKE
SURE IT’S NOT YOUR SPOUSE’S
BIKINI BOTTOMS.
>> IN ORDER FOR US TO GET BACK
TO NORMAL, WE’VE GOT TO DO
ABNORMAL THINGS.
IF YOU AND ME WHO ARE GOING TO
LEAD ALL OF US OUT OF THIS MESS.
WE NEED TO BE TRUSTED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
UNLIKE OUR LEADERS, WE CAN SHARE
THE RISK.
WE CAN SAY, LET’S GO BACK TO
WORK WITH PROTOCOLS IN PLACE.
YES, THERE’S A
YES, THERE’S A RISK THE DISEASE
WILL RETURN BUT THAT’S THE RISK
AND WE AS A COUNTRY CHAIR AND
WILL ACT ACCORDINGLY.
WE CAN DO THAT SO OUR LEADERS
FOLLOW.
THE REVERSE MAY NOT HAPPEN.
LEADERS ARE FEARFUL OF RISK
BECAUSE THE MEDIA HANGS ALL THE
CASUALTIES ROUND THEIR NECKS.
IF WE SHARE THE RISK, THE MEDIA
CAN’T ATTACK ALL OF US.
I MEDIA FULL OF TAX LOOKING TO
THE FUTURE, AS LONG AS THE
FUTURE ALREADY HAPPENS.
THEY ARE THE HINDQUARTERS OF
HINDSIGHT.
THEY JUST CAN’T STOP.
>> IT’S EXACTLY THE KIND OF
CHAOS HE’S BROUGHT TO BEAR ON
THE PRICES FROM THE BEGINNING.
GREG: NOW THAT WE HAVE OVER
46000 AMERICANS DEAD BECAUSE OF
IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS GIVING
DANGEROUS SUGGESTIONS, INCLUDING
INJECTING A PERSON WITH
DISINFECTANT.
>> IT TOOK A COLORBLIND, GENDER
BLIND, STATE LINES, VIRUS TO
HAVE ALL OF THE PRESIDENT SENT
FROM HIS FIRST THREE YEARS CATCH
UP.
I WONDER IF YOU THINK ABOUT A
SILVER LINING THERE.
GREG: SELF THE SILVER LINING TO
50000 DEAD IS THAT IT REALLY
HURT THE GUY I HATE WITH EVERY
FIBER OF MY THING.
WHAT A SAD SOUL, TO BE SO
EMOTIONALLY CORRECT THAT SHE
FIND A SILVER LINING IN MASS
DEATH.
WHAT DO I KNOW?
I’M JUST A GUY WHO WOULD DO
ANYTHING.
WHAT STINKS, JONATHAN CAP AND
MAYOR OF NEW YORK?
DID YOU KNOW HE WAS SHOCKED THE
INMATE HE RELEASED FROM JAIL
OVER FEARS THEY WOULD GET SICK,
AND IS UP REOFFENDING?
I KNOW, SURPRISED.
I WONDER WHAT ELSE SHOCKED DE
BLASIO.
BIG THINGS ARE HEAVY?
FIRE IS HOT?
NO ONE LIKES HIM?
THIS TALL DRINK OF DOPE, IT WAS
UNCONSCIONABLE THE CRIMINALS
WOULD COMMIT CRIME.
THIS MORON WAS RELYING ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF FOLKS.
WORSE, AFTER HE REALIZED
DOWNPLAYING THE VIRUS WAS WRONG,
HE URGED CITIZENS TO WORK ON
EACH OTHER.
>> YOU SEE A CROWD, A LINE
THAT’S NOT DISTANCING, A
SUPERMARKET TO CROWDED,
ANYTHING, REPORTED RIGHT AWAY SO
WE CAN GET HELP THERE TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
IT’S AS SIMPLE AS TAKING A
PHOTO.
ALL YOU DO IS TAKE THE PHOTO AND
PUT THE LOCATION WITH IT AND
BANK, SENT A PHOTO LIKE THIS AND
WE WILL MAKE SURE ENFORCEMENT
COMES RIGHT AWAY.
GREG: AMAZING.
HE’S TURNING CITIZENS INTO
MODERATES COFFEE.
SUREFIRE WAY TO DIVIDE PEOPLE IN
A TIME OF CRISIS.
WHO THINGS LIKE THIS?
THINK GOD FOR AMERICANS BECAUSE
THE RESPONSE TO THIS IS
DISTINCTLY WONDERFULLY AMERICAN.
WHEN HE ANNOUNCED THE TO.TO SEND
AGAINST YOUR NEIGHBOR’S?
FLOODED HIS LINE WITH PORN,
PICTURES OF GENITALIA AND DE
BLASIO.
IT’S HARD TO TELL THE DIFFERENCE
THOUGH.
I MUST STOP AND SAY I LOVE YOU,
I DO.
IT’S THE GREATEST THING YOU CAN
DO AS AN AMERICAN, AMERICA WITH
"BIG BROTHER" BOZO URGING HIM TO
TURN ON YOUR FELLOW MAN, SENT
HIM PORNO SHOTS.
THE FOUNDING FATHERS WERE ALIVE
RIGHT NOW, THEY WOULD KISS YOUR
FEET AND THEN LOOK AT THE POND.
I KNOW THESE OTHER PROTESTS ARE
COMPLICATED ON ONE HAND, THE
PROTESTING GOVERNMENT OVERREACH,
WHICH MAKES THEM AS AMERICAN AS
A PICKUP TRUCK FULL OF SMALLER
PICKUP TRUCKS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WHICH I CAN’T
TOUCH, THEY ARE CONGREGATING
WHICH COULD SPREAD THE VIRUS.
IF WE SLAM THE SPRING BREAKERS,
WE’VE GOT TO DO THE SAME HERE.
IT’S WRONG TO PROTEST WITHOUT
PROTECTION.
WITH ALSO RUN, WITH CELEBRITIES
WHO CALL THEMSELVES ALLIES OF
THE WORKING CLASS, NOW MARKING
THE ACTUAL WORKING CLASS.
YOU KNOW WHO’S NOT TALKING?
THIS GUY.
PUT A HOLD ON GREEN CARDS.
IF YOU’RE NOT LETTING AMERICANS
OUT TO WORK, WHY LET WORKERS
INTO WORK?
THIS WILL BE CALLED RACIST
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT THE PDF
DOES, IT TRIVIALIZES A WORD
UNTIL IT HAS NO MEANING.
NEVER MIND ALTERING NEW GREEN
CARDS IS WHAT YOU DO WHEN
TEMPORARY UNEMPLOYMENT
SKYROCKETS.
AN IDIOT WOULD INVITE MORE
PEOPLE INTO A SINKING BOAT.
THE STOPPAGE HELPS THE
MINORITIES HERE.
TRUMP HELPED SOLIDIFY BY
DEMANDING HARVARD RETURN THE
MILLIONS THAT GOT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT NEVER HURTS TO ASK OR DEMAND
IN PUBLIC.
STILL HARVARD SAID THEY DIDN’T
ASK FOR THE BAILOUT SO I GUESS
THAT MONEY JUST WANTED TO GO TO
HARVARD?
BUT THE MEDIA IGNORED THAT
STORY.
I’VE HAD IT WITH THEM.
I CAN TOLERATE THEIR BS BUT WE
ARE WASTING TIME ABOUT WHETHER
THE OSCARS ARE DIVERSE ENOUGH
BUT NOT HERE.
THIS IS A FUTURE OF AMERICA WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT TRAINED GENDER, THIS
BEHAVIOR IS SELFISH AND GROSS,
WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVE TO BE OWN
JOURNALISTS.
FOCUS ON FACTS AND NOT
NARRATIVES.
WE ARE FACED WITH ADULT
QUESTIONS AND EVERY DECISION
CARRIES A RISK.
GOING BACK TO WORK WON’T BE EASY
BUT WE CAN’T NOT GO BACK.
IT’S NOT IN THE CARDS OR OUR
BLOOD.
WE HAVE THE ROADMAP AND IT OVER
ROCKY TERRAIN.
WE KNOW THE VIRUS, EVEN IF IT
FLATTENS, CAN RETURN.
AMERICA IS A BATTLEFIELD AND IT
CAN COME OUT OF HIDING BUT WE
CAN’T REMAIN IN HIDING FOREVER.
WE NEED TO COME BACK.
IN PHASES WITH OPTIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR RETREAT WHEN
NECESSARY.
MAYBE JUST TRUST AMERICANS TO
KNOW HOW TO AVOID HAZARDS TO